Tom, considering that you're the one
in charge of this shoot,
why did you make us
do jousting?
It's not so much that I'm in charge of this.
It's that at some point,
in the last few weeks,
someone on the team said,
"Hey Tom, how about jousting?"
and I went, "Yeah, sure."
And...
Now it's happening.
I'm not sure how I feel about it,
to be honest.
I've never— I've never
ridden a horse.
Thrilled, excited!
Yeah, yeah. Nervous.
I don't think we're gonna—
Heroic.
I don't think we're gonna be
jousting each other.
I think this is a tournament.
This is a competition.
Okay well, I'm out of here,
'cause I was mainly here
for the bodily harm towards you.
You were mainly here to stab me in the chest.
But now, it's games, okay.
(gasp)
Oh my god, they're so big.
(laughs uproariously)
I nearly said that. I thought,
is that too obvious to say?
I don't think I've ever been
close to a horse in my life.
I've seen horses.
I don't wanna sound stupid here.
I've seen— I've never been...
close to a horse before.
But when you have, it's never been
when you're about to get on top of it
and to be the height
of the back of a horse.
Yeah, that's—
Which suddenly makes them look like
the tallest animals
that have ever existed.
Hello!
So cute!
Hello guys, so these are
your horses for the day.
Tom, you will be riding Freddie...
Alright. Hello.
...for the day.
And you have the lovely Toby.
Oh!  Whoa!
(laughs)
That— That's fine.
Thanks, Toby.
I like how you caught that.
And saved it,
and I just went, nope!
So what we will do is
we'll get you both mounted up,
adjust the stirrup level for you both,
and then we'll crack on.
Alright. (chuckles)
Let's go.
You've done this once before, right?
Yeah, one time.
Is there a knack to this?
Yeah, so I'll talk you through it
as we get to it.
I see you giggling there!
Hee-hee-hee.
You've got to do this in a minute as well!
It's good that you're going first,
'cause all I have to do is
be better than you at getting
on the horse and then it'll be fine.
You're gonna place
your left foot into this stirrup.
Alright.
And then hold the front
and the back of the saddle.
Hold the front and back of the saddle.
Gimme a second. I'll just hold this stirrup.
Of course the stirrup moves! I just...
And you're gonna swing your right leg
over the back of the horse.
That's it. Perfect.
Okay, well that— Yep— Thank you—
That was beautifully done!
If you'll pop your right foot into this bit.
That was very well done!
Lovely.
So that is— I'll just tuck that...
Alright.
If you'd just— Sorry, I'm just...
Do you feel one with the horse, Tom?
No, not at all.
(giggles)
I am on the horse.
More than that... I'm just not...
Well, I'll ask you again at the end.
See if you've formed a lasting friendship.
Yep.
So you're gonna have your left rein
between your thumb and your first finger,
and your right rein between your
first and second finger.
Okay.
Just like that.
These horses are trained
to neck rein, so effectively,
taking your hand at the neck
is like taking your handbrake off.
(chuckles)
And then...
Thank you. That's the analogy
I've got. That's fine.
So you take your handbrake off,
and then you give it a little bit of gas.
So that's with your legs.
Alright, yep.
As soon as he's took off, then
you completely relax your legs off him.
Yep.
'Cause the more pressure
you put on him,
the faster he's gonna want to run.
Right, okay, yep.
And then when you want to go left,
you're simply gonna take,
so with your hands still up at his neck,
you will take your hand
over to the left.
He will feel this round on his neck,
and he will respond away from it.
So the higher up the neck he feels that,
the more response there's gonna be.
So that's the same for left and for right,
and then when you wish to stop,
you're simply gonna bring your hand
into your belt buckle.
These reins are connected
to this bit in his mouth,
and that's gonna tell him
that you want him to slow down.
Okay... I think
I can remember all that.
You got all that as well, Rowan?
So I am a lesbian,
and therefore don't drive.
(Tom and Will laugh)
So the car analogies...
I've done the Legoland Racers,
but they didn't have a handbrake,
but I think I'm puzzling it out
Okay.
at the same time.
Okay Rowan,
if you'd like to come over,
I am ready.
we're gonna introduce you to Toby.
Hello, Toby!
So if you'll just step over here for me.
Hello.
And make your way 'round onto the steps.
Onto the steps.
Make your way up to the top step.
Okay.
Then you're gonna put
your left foot in this stirrup.
Got it.
Very good.
Bring your right leg over.
Perfect!
Feeling okay?
Feeling good.
Right then, let's get these horses moving.
Oh god!
Whilst we're stood still
here together,
I just wanna go through some of the
motions that you're gonna feel
when we move from
walking into trot.
So what I'd like you to do is,
when we trot,
we do what's called a rising trot.
So as the horse moves,
it's got a natural up-and-down,
rise-and-fall movement.
So you will then have to
kind of counteract that
by controlling your own rise
and your fall,
so that we take out the bounce element
on the horse's back.
And it just keeps them
more comfortable,
and enables you guys to then focus on
the skills that we're gonna introduce you to.
So if you'll just do that again,
so like an up and down, up and down.
So right, let's get these horses
warmed up,
and then we'll go through a little bit more
of the riding elements with yourselves,
and then we'll crack straight on
with some skills.
Cool. Okay.
Okay then.
I'm gonna send you off
and just have a trot next to you.
We're gonna run alongside you,
and really just get you to feel that
rise and fall that we talked about earlier.
♪ (light, folksy adventure music)
Up, down. Up, down.
So...
I feel like I'm out of phase here.
I feel like I'm...
...doing the opposite of
what's needed here.
(music ends)
Just think about pushing all that weight
through your legs into the balls of your feet.
Keeping your shoulders back
and your chin up.
Your right hand away from the saddle.
Yep!
And then taking that bounce
out of the trot.
Okay.
A lot to think about...
Alright.
...but I'm sure you can do it.
Okay, yep.
Okay, let's go again.
Hand forward slightly. That's it.
Hand forward, kick on.
Little kick on.
Yeah.
That's it. So we're gonna go
up, down, up, down, up, down.
Up, down, up, down, up, down.
Right, yes! This looks a lot better.
Just keep yourself...
Set your weight centred.
Oh no, hold on, whoa, no.
'Cause you're...
Yeah.
God dammit! Alright.
I should be able to nail
the timing on this, and I can't.
Toby, babes, I don't know if I've got
the core strength for this,
but we're gonna see it through together.
Alright then, let's go.
So I'm gonna control
the speed of the horse for now.
Sure.
There we go.
So you're gonna go,
up, down, up, down,
up, down, up, down.
Nope.
So control that fall...
...as much as you're pushing out.
I feel like I'm at the wrong rhythm.
I don't know which—
Okay, so kick him on again,
give him a good squeeze at your feet.
So now, up, down.
Yeah, you've got it.
That's it, nice!
Woo...!
(giggles)
Yeah look, really good.
There we go.
Okay.
Really nice.
Phew.
So you've got now the basics.
Sure.
The real basics.
So we're gonna crack on with some skills,
and we'll face it as we go along.
Let's go.
Awesome.
How are you doing on the trot?
I dunno, I was just sorta bouncing around,
and apparently it was good, so.
Oh well, you're doing better than me then.
I cannot, cannot nail the timing on this.
I'm just gonna have to keep trying it.
You've got this.
There'll be plenty of time
for practice throughout the day.
Yeah, we'll be fine.
So I'm gonna get a ring lance
and explain to you
what your first skill is gonna be.
Sure!
(Tom and Rowan giggling)
No, I'm being left hanging.
I'm being... I'm being left hanging.
Oh, sorry!
Oh no, that wasn't very
inner cowboy of me.
So guys, these are your ring lances.
We are gonna use these
for your first skill,
which is the
lancing of the gold rings.
So as you see, along the tilt,
we have our crown rings.
When I hand you these lances,
you will hold them in your right hand.
We're gonna take them away from our body,
down to a horizontal position,
up into that armpit, and
hook your elbow into your hips.
Take them from the right-hand side,
up and over the horse's head
to the left-hand side.
Once you've got your first ring,
do not move your lance anywhere,
and there's no reason why you
should not then get your second ring.
No reason at all(!)
Yeah, sure(!)
Are we ready to give a go?
We'll give it a go.
I feel ridiculously underqualified
for this, let's go!
How're you feeling?
Great. My hand-eye coordination
is such that I...
I'm sure that I will get
not one, but two rings,
as Will so confidently predicted
that we will be able to do(!)
Sure we'll be fine. How about you?
How're you feeling?
Mmh, this is— I am—
I am not comfortable right now!
This does not feel like
a thing I'm capable of doing.
We'll see how it goes.
We'll give it a go.
Yep, yep.
That's all we can do is try!
So I want you to bring that lance down
between me and the horse.
That's it. Get it up into that armpit.
Got it.
And now track it up and over his head.
Up and over.
So look directly through that ring...
and then make minor adjustments
with that hand.
Oh god, okay.
Come on, Toby.
I won't let you down.
There we go!
♪ There we go ♪
Okay so, when you're ready,
bring your lance down.
Right.
Lance goes down— Wheeey, yeah.
Lance is down. Yep.
That's it.
Up and over the horse's head.
Look directly through those rings.
Look directly through the ring.
And...
...collect it.
Hey, okay.
Yeah, well done.
Number two, line it up.
And now are we gonna get the next one?
Ohh!
Oh, that's a miss. Unlucky.
I nearly got the camera lens, mind!
♪ (light, slow folksy music)
No! Ugh!
...with your left hand.
Come on!
There we go.
Nope.
You're good, you're good.
No, it isn't!
Ah.
No, you little...
Give him another kick.
Well we tried, Toby...!
That's one.
Yeah! Come on.
That's two!
Yes!
One.
Nice.
Oh, missed it!
Oh, look back.
Missed that.
No! I'm getting worse!
Oh, unlucky.
Yes!
Yeah!
(music ends)
Gah!
Easy, easy, easy!
Whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa!
Drop that.
Hooh.
What was that all about then?
What was that?
There's something up there
he didn't like.
You okay?
Yeah, I'm okay.
You feeling okay?
Yeah. (pants and chuckles)
Whew. Tell me we got that on camera!
Little bit of adrenaline
there at the end.
Yep.
There was a— I don't know
if the microphone will cover it.
There was a loud noise behind, and...
...someone got a little bit
startled there!
You!
Yes.
So guys, our next strength is gonna be
the striking of the quintain.
Now this here is our quintain.
It is a wooden man-shaped target,
used to test the knight's accuracy,
on the shield,
and strength, the combined strength
of the rider and the horse.
So what we would like you to do is shortly,
we're gonna hand you a quintain lance.
It's very much like your ring lances.
If you don't have it
couched in properly,
on impact, that lance is gonna
pop out from your armpit,
and can do one of many things,
but one is to effectively clothesline yourself
off the back of the horse.
I don't know why I'm laughing.
That's terrifying.
(laughs)
Now, the idea being that you're gonna
hit this part of the quintain,
and it is gonna spin 'round.
Now, the more you
continue moving past it,
the less likely you are
to get hit by the ball.
To get attacked.
...Okay.
When these would've been used
back in medieval times,
this would have had a
really heavy, spiky ball on.
And if you didn't strike
the quintain properly,
or you didn't continue your ride
away from the quintain,
you would get a punishment
of being hit by the ball.
Right then, are we ready to start?
...All good to go.
Sure.
Okay, so you're gonna aim for
that top right-hand part of the shield.
Yeah.
And we don't fall,
we let it hit.
There we go.    Yaay.
That is—
Keep going forwards.
Yep.
Really squeeze.
(drolly) Bang.
♪ (driving adventure music)
So keep that shoulder back.
Yep.
Nice! Really nice hit.
(panting loudly)
Up, down, up, down,
up, down, up, down.
Come— keep going!
Keep kicking, keep kicking.
Here we go!
Top right-hand corner!
Wow! Awesome!
Yes!
No! Wrong way, Toby!
You're good. Yes!
Keep going, Toby!
Come on, come on, and...
Hit! Yes!
Yay, really nice.
I was convinced that flail
was about to hit my head there!
Yes!
You doing good?
Keep going!
Come on, come on, come on!
That's it.
Yes!
Good, nice!
Alright.
(music ends)
So that is all of your training
done for this morning.
We're gonna break for a minute,
and collect ourselves, have a bit of lunch.
And then we're gonna come back out here,
for the Grand Gauntlet Challenge,
huzzah!
So at any point
that you hear me say,
"The Grand Gauntlet Challenge,
huzzah!"
you will follow it with
a big renowned-ing, "Huzzah!"
So we're gonna try that once more,
once I have taken these lances from you.
This is exactly—
You're like, it's too dangerous with the lances.
Let's give 'em one thing at a time.
This is exactly the sort of thing
that I am immediately cynical about.
It's gonna take a while for me
to warm up, to get the word in there.
So let's try this again.
When we return after lunch,
we are gonna partake
in what we call,
the Grand Gauntlet Challenge!
(in unison) Huzzah!
Very good.
There's still a layer of irony
on that for me.
I can't quite get there yet.
Commit to the bit, Tom! Come on.
Yeah, we need full commitment this afternoon.
(giggles)
This afternoon, we are gonna combine
all the skills you have learned this morning.
And we're gonna put it into a
one-after-the-other challenge.
You will be competing
against each other for this.
And there's a little surprise in store
at the end of the day,
but you will be in full knightly gear
this afternoon.
So let's take a break now.
(softly) ...Huzzah!
Get ourselves and horses into costume,
and we'll come back out here shortly.
I saved about £400 on renting this car,
thanks to NordVPN, seriously.
I'm on the road a lot
at the moment,
and it turns out that things like car rental
are sometimes priced differently,
not based on who you are,
not on how well you drive,
not on where your billing address is,
but instead where the
company's website thinks you are.
Because I was able to use the magic
NordVPN button on my laptop and phone
that told the rental place
I'm still in the UK,
I saved over a third of
what this rental would have cost.
I don't know why.
Maybe I could've saved more
if I'd picked a different one of the
60 or so countries that NordVPN supports,
but I was happy enough with that.
Plus, that magic button means
I can access content that's geolocked,
like if I'm trying to do research,
and a US news site blocks all Europeans,
because they can't be bothered to comply
with the local privacy laws,
which happens to be a surprising
amount when I'm in Europe.
Although if you are going to
try that with streaming video,
check with the service's
terms and conditions first.
You can use NordVPN on
six devices at the same time.
It's never slowed down my browsing.
It's lightning-fast as far as I can tell.
And if it turns out
not to work for you, no bother.
There's a 30-day money-back guarantee.
If you go to
nordvpn.com/tomscottplus,
you'll find the best deal
they're currently offering.
Right, back to the horsing around.
♪ (soaring heraldic music)
♪ (triumphant adventure music)
(music warbles out)
(wheezing)
We look great. I think we look fantastic.
Very professional.
Will... Will looks fantastic.
Will has hair and cape
flowing in the breeze.
Beautiful. We look like
contestants in a game show...
Yeah.
...who are about to get gunged or something.
We've got the mic on here
and everything.
It's a strong look.
Yeah.
♪ (dramatic adventure music)
(music stings out)
Okay, welcome knights!
So we are now ready to start
the Grand Gauntlet Challenge.
Huzzah!    Huzzah!
Huzzah.
(chuckles) I'll work on it!
(giggles)
So we're gonna get you mounted up,
and then we're gonna see
who's gonna be our victor
this afternoon.
Right then, let's go.
We're gonna start off with the
collection of the gold rings.
Each ring is worth one point.
There's four points
available on the tilt.
Then we will strike the quintain
once in each direction.
Another point available for a
good, strong, solid hit on the quintain.
So a total of six points
available for you here.
Are we ready?
Yes!
Right then, let's go.
You ready?
Yep.
(rough metal clanking)
Huzzah!
Come on, come on, off we go.
Okay, so first up to ride,
we have...
♪ (dramatic adventure music)
Lady Rowan the Radiant!
Okay, when you're ready,
my lady, you shall ride!
(blunt clattering)
That's one.
Two, nice!
I think she's got it.
Hey, she's got it!
Ooh.
On that one, come on.
Nope.
Okay, two.
Up, and it's really tight?
Yes, [indistinct]
Okay, cool.
Ready?
Okay, come on, Toby. You can do it.
(clamouring)
Nicely done!
Whew.
Nice. Bring it up.
(music ends)
(softly) Yay!
Well done.
Okay, so next up to ride,
we have...
Thomas the Uncertain!
Okay, Thomas!
Yay!
When you are ready,
my lord, please ride!
♪ (dramatic adventure music)
Alright, here we go.
Go, trot on!
Come on, come on, come on.
No!
Yes! That's one.
That's one, that's— whoa, whoa, whoa.
Trot on! Here we go!
Come on, come on,
come on!
No!
Gaaah!
And I lost a stirrup as well!
Oh no.
(panting heavily)
Come on, come on, come on.
Right hand corner, just right.
Yes!
(music ends)
Yes! Two points, Thomas!
That's a total of two points for the quintain,
and one point from the rings.
(chuckling exhaustedly)
I was trying so damn hard
on that last ring!
You did really well though.
I mean, not quite as well, milady.
I hate to say that. It sounds wrong, but...
Thank you so much.
(laughs)
If you'd just doff your little fedora to me,
thank you so much.
Right then guys,
so at the end of that challenge,
Rowan, you're on four points,
and Tom, you had three.
Meaning Rowan, you are the winner
of our Grand Gauntlet Challenge.
Huzzah!
Huzzah!    Huzzah!
Which means that today, you get to joust
against a real-life Knight of Middle England.
I— Let's do it.
Good luck.
Let's go.
♪ (menacing adventure music)
(slow-warped) Huzzah!
(music ends)
Yes, we did a thing.
(polite clapping)
And I assume I hit him, 'cause we
definitely didn't script it that way...!
Thank you so much, squire.
How was that?
That was great. That was so fun.
I definitely hit him,
which is the aim of the game.
So I'm feeling victorious
from that point of view.
Thank you so much for coming down.
Thank you for inviting me.
I did not realise at the start of the day
that I would end it as a knight,
but you've given me that opportunity,
and for that, I can only thank you.
Huzzah!
That's it. Have a little moment.
...Ow!
(uproarious laugh)
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]